foreign
conflict
is
foreign
as recently
[Music]
is
um
is
um
[Music]
and germans
ukrainian politics are
trying to
are against the national interest of
ukraine but if the goal of building
peace on their own land is part of the
national interest of ukraine
another excuse that we hear here is that
there is no mention
at this meeting of ours
and the order in which they are to be
implemented is very clearly stated it
cannot be changed
first
second withdrawal
monitoring for launching your dialogue
between cleveland passes
exchange of detainees
humanitarian access
lifting the economic blockade
eleven new constitutions providing
special status
twelve agreeing on the order of
conducting elections and 13 intensifying
the work of the contractors
on the road
that none of the
provisions have been implemented
whereas this is a dialogue that is
clearly
directly provided in items
of the document this is not our
requirement this is something that is
stated in the document it says
obligation on ukraine and this is
something that our neighbors
increasingly bring into question and
with us uh
risk undermines process which could lead
to some devastating gospels
um
[Music]
attempts to place the blame
very disappointed by the ostrich-like
position of our western colleagues who
are trying not to see obvious things we
are surprised that they're putting to uh
this shadow the men's complexion
placing the emphasis on the normal
format
to for the western um sponsors to exert
pressure on kiev to implement his
agreements
and they were doing exactly the opposite
so the increasing feeling of impunity to
push the ukrainian hot hats to new
excuses and military adventures against
their own people and this is what we
have we have thousands uh
are still
presented as foreigners in their their
own country they have uh automatic
rifles sniper rifles howitzers and um
a memorial complex in donetsk
force of um 20 people died
dozens were wounded a 24 year old
anastasia a local was there
actually
at the time
ukrainian
military using a prohibited means of
waste
and our u.n mission compiled that and
disseminated this from members of
security
um
measures which prohibits the prosecution
and punishment of persons in
i would like to finally say that you
will be able to resist the temptation to
play to the cameras and will not make
this meeting around the circus
i think we've had enough speculation on
that including the security um council
meeting on the thursday first of january
convened
is behind us so therefore i'm my advice
mr anthony blinken secretary of state of
the united states of america
mr president
this council was convened today
to discuss the implementation of the
minsk agreements
a goal that we all share
despite russia's persistent violations
these agreements which were negotiated
in 2014 and 2015 and signed by russia
remain the basis
for the peace process to resolve the
conflict in eastern ukraine
this council's primary responsibility
the very reason for its creation
is the preservation of peace and
security
as we meet today
the most immediate threat to peace and
security
is russia's looming aggression against
ukraine
the stakes go far beyond ukraine
this is a moment of peril for the lives
and safety of millions of people as well
as for the foundation of the united
nations charter
and the rules-based international order
that preserves stability worldwide
this crisis directly affects
every member of this council and every
country in the world
because the basic principles that
sustain peace and security
principles that were enshrined in the
wake of two world wars and a cold war
are under threat
the principle that
one country cannot change the borders of
another by force
the principle that one country cannot
dictate another's choices or policies or
with whom it will associate
the principle of national sovereignty
this is the exact kind of crisis that
the united nations
and specifically
this security council
was created to prevent
we must address what russia is doing
right now
to ukraine
over the past months
without provocation or justification
russia has amassed more than 150 000
troops around ukraine's borders
in russia belarus
occupied crimea
russia says it's throwing down those
forces
we do not see that happening on the
ground
our information indicates clearly that
these forces
including ground troops
aircraft ships
are preparing to launch an attack
against ukraine
in the coming days
we don't know precisely how things will
play out
but here's what the world can expect to
see unfold
in fact it's unfolding right now
today
as russia takes steps down the path to
war and reissued the threat of military
action
first
russia plans to manufacture a pretext
for its attack
this could be a violent event that
russia will bring on ukraine or an
outrageous accusation that russia will
level against the ukrainian government
we don't know exactly the form it will
take
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of the mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons
russia may describe this event as ethnic
cleansing
or a genocide
making a mockery of a concept that we in
this chamber do not take lightly
nor do i take lightly based on my family
history
in the past few days
russian media has already begun to
spread some of these false alarms
and claims
to maximize public outrage
to lay the groundwork for an invented
justification for war
today
that drum beat has only intensified in
russia's state-controlled media
we've heard some of these basic
allegations from russian-backed speakers
here today
second
in response to this manufactured
provocation
the highest levels of the russian
government
may theatrically convene emergency
meetings
to address the so-called crisis
the government will issue proclamations
declaring that mushroom must respond to
defend russian citizens or ethnic
russians in ukraine
next
the attack is planned to begin
russian missiles and bombs will drop
across ukraine
communications will be jammed
cyber attacks will shut down key
ukrainian institutions
after that
russian tanks and soldiers will advance
on key targets that have already been
identified and mapped out in detailed
plans
we believe these targets include
russia's capital ukraine's capital kiev
a city of 2.8 million people
and conventional attacks
are not all that russia plans to inflict
upon the people of ukraine
we have information that indicates
russia will target specific groups of
ukrainians
we've been warning the ukrainian
government of all that is coming
and here today
we are laying it out in great detail
with the hope that by sharing what we
know with the world
we can influence russia to abandon the
path of war
and choose a different path
while there's still time
now
i'm mindful that
some have called into question our
information
recalling previous instances where
intelligence ultimately did not bear out
but let me be clear
i am here today
not to start a war
but to prevent one
the information i presented here
is validated by what we've seen
unfolding in plain sight
before our eyes for months
and remember that while russia has
repeatedly derided our warnings and
alarms as melodrama and nonsense
they have been steadily amassing more
than 150 000 troops on ukraine's borders
as well as the capabilities to conduct a
massive military assault
it isn't just us seeing this
allies and partners see the same thing
and russia hasn't only been hearing from
us
the international chorus
has grown louder and louder
if russia doesn't invade ukraine
then we will be relieved
that russia changed course
and proved our predictions wrong
that would be a far better outcome than
the course we're currently on
and we'll gladly accept any criticism
that anyone directs at us
as president biden said
this would be a war of choice and if
russia makes that choice
we've been clear
along with allies and partners
that our response will be sharp
and decisive
president biden reiterated that
forcefully earlier this week
there's another choice russia can still
make
if there's any truth to its claim
that is committed to diplomacy
diplomacy is the only responsible way to
resolve this
crisis an essential part of this is
through implementation of the minsk
agreements the subject of our session
today
there are series of commitments that
russia and ukraine made under minsk
with the osce and the normandy format
partners involved as well
if russia is prepared to sit with the
ukrainian government
and work through the process of
implementing these commitments
our friends in france and germany stand
ready to convene senior level
discussions in the normandy format
to settle these issues
ukraine is ready for this
and we stand fully ready to support the
parties
progress toward resolving the donbass
crisis through the minsk agreements can
reinforce the broader discussions on
security issues that we're prepared to
engage in with russia in coordination
with our allies and partners
more than three weeks ago
we provided russia with a paper
that detailed concrete reciprocal steps
that we can take in the near term
to address our respective concerns
and advance the collective security
interests of russia
the united states
and our european partners and allies
this morning we received a response
which we're evaluating
earlier today
i sent a letter to russia's foreign
minister sergey lavrov
proposing that we meet next week in
europe
following on our talks in recent weeks
to discuss the steps that we can take to
resolve this crisis without conflict
we're also proposing meetings of the
nato-russia council and the osce
permanent council
these meetings can pave the way for a
summit of key leaders
in the context of de-escalation
to reach understandings on our mutual
security concerns
as lead diplomats for our nations we
have a responsibility to make every
effort for diplomacy to succeed
to leave no diplomatic stone unturned
if russia is committed to diplomacy
we're presenting every opportunity for
it to demonstrate that commitment
i have no doubt that
the response to my remarks here today
will be more dismissals from the russian
government about the united states
stoking hysteria or that it has no plans
to invade ukraine
so let me make this simple
the russian government can announce
today
with no qualification equivocation or
deflection
that russia will not invade ukraine
state it clearly
state it plainly to the world
and then demonstrate it
by sending your troops
your tanks your planes
back to their barracks and hangers
and sending your diplomats to the
negotiating table
in the coming days
the world will remember that commitment
or
the refusal to make it
i yield the floor
mr james cleverley
i thank you and i thank the briefers for
the information they've given today
the united nations the osce and the
mandate of the osce special monitoring
mission
continue to command our full support
the rights of all ukrainian
whether they are in kiev lev
donetsk
luhansk can only be served by peace
diplomacy
and dialogue
i want to make absolutely clear the
united kingdom's support for the
implementation of the minsk agreements
as endorsed by u.n security council
resolution 2202
that resolution reaffirmed the security
council's full respect for the
sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
of ukraine it remains the responsibility
of all parties
to implement fully their commitments
and to seek a peaceful resolution to the
conflict
in this respect we condemn the actions
taken by the russian duma
to propose the russian president
recognize the regions
of luhansk and donetsk as independent
this would directly undermine the minsk
agreements
and must be rejected by the russian
authorities in line with the commitments
that they have made
we welcome all efforts to support the
process and to avoid escalation
including the role of the osce and the
normandy format this remains our
long-standing position
mr president let us remind ourselves of
the context for the minst minsk
agreements and the situation in which
ukraine finds itself today
in march 2014 russia invaded
and illegally annexed crimea
in flagrant violation of international
law
a few weeks later in april
russia instigated a conflict in the
donbass
which it continues to fuel today more
than 14 000 people
have lost their lives in the fighting
there
now
today
the ukrainian people are yet again
living under the threat of invasion with
well over 130 000 russian troops heavy
weaponry and military vessels amassed
and exercising on their northern
eastern
and southern borders from belarus
to the black sea
let us say clearly what the whole world
can see
russia
has deployed the forces necessary to
invade ukraine
and now
has them readied for action
in the past days we have heard russian
claims that some units are returning to
barracks it is however
all too clear that the opposite is in
fact true
and the russian military buildup
continues
russia will say that it has the right to
move its forces within its own territory
but
no one has the right to threaten the use
of force
russia is patently failing to live up to
the international commitments that it
has made around military transparency by
refusing to adequately explain its
military build up or provide the
necessary transparency to build trust
and to de-escalate the situation
if the kremlin is serious about a
diplomatic resolution then it needs to
show up to the diplomatic meetings and
commit to meaningful osce talks
including via chapter 3 of the osce
vienna document
they did not show up on wednesday and
they do not intend to show up
on friday
russia's actions are clearly designed to
intimidate
to threaten
and to destabilize ukraine we know it
they know it
and the international community knows it
mr president russia called this meeting
today
to discuss resolution 2202
that text is very clear on two points
that reflect the core tenets of the
charter
emphasized by the united nations
secretary general when he addressed this
situation only a few days ago
one
the resolving the situation in eastern
regions of ukraine can only be achieved
by peaceful means
and two
that there must be full respect for the
sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
of ukraine
yet
we are seeing increasing disinformation
about events in the donbass that are
straight out of the kremlin playbook
a blatant attempt by the russian
government to fabricate a pretext for
the invasion of ukraine
it is therefore clear that we are at a
critical juncture
to prevent further escalation
up holding the core tenants of the
charter in respect of peaceful
resolution and respecting sovereign
sovereignty and territorial integrity
has never been more important
russia must now engage with the
diplomatic process we have built up over
several decades and on which global
security depends and resolve
this situation
through peaceful means
if russia chooses to launch an attack
at this time of heightened tension
using disinformation of a pretext
it will show that russia was never
serious about diplomatic engagement
any russian invasion now would be a
conflict of choice
for president putin and an abdication of
russia's responsibility under the un
charter
to refrain from the use of force and to
maintain international peace
and security there should be no doubt
that any further russian incursion into
ukraine would be a massive strategic
mistake and a humanitarian disaster that
will be met with strength including
significant coordinated sanctions
and we will continue to call out the
pattern of deception and disinformation
from the russian state
but
if russia is serious about the charter
and its role as a permanent member of
this council
it should give the minsk agreements the
chance to be implemented free from
coercion it should engage seriously
with
diplomacy and it should stand down all
of its troops
there is still time to change path
conflict
can be avoided and we urge russia to
match its words
with actions
to withdraw its troops
to engage meaningfully in talks and to
act in the best interest
of peace
and security
and stability in europe i thank you
[Music]
norway
[Music]
thank you president and i thank the
briefers for their statements
let me also use this opportunity to
thank all personnel at the osce special
monitoring mission to ukraine
they contribute on a daily basis to
reducing tensions and fostering peace
stability and security on the ground
the threatening security situation in
and around ukraine is alarming
norway is deeply concerned by russian
large-scale military buildup in occupied
crimea
to the north
east and south of ukraine as well as in
belarus and the black sea
the alleged reports of increased
shelling are disturbing they must not be
used as a pretext for any military
action
norway calls on russia to de-escalate
and to engage in dialogue constructively
and in good faith
through established international
mechanisms
it remains a major obstacle that russia
falsely seeks to portray the conflict in
eastern ukraine as an internal ukrainian
conflict
the reality is that russia has fueled
the conflict by providing financial and
military support to the armed formations
it backs
president norway expresses strong
concern regarding the resolution of the
russian state duma calling for the
recognition of the self-proclaimed
people's republics of donetsk and
luhansk
we warn against such a step which would
constitute a further violation of
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity and directly contradict the
spirit and the letter of the minsk
agreements
norway supports the negotiations in the
normandy format and in the trilateral
contact group aimed at ending the
conflict through a political settlement
and implementation of the minsk
agreements
norway calls on the parties to uphold
their commitments and to engage
constructively towards resolving the
conflict by peaceful means
we welcome the osce chairmanship's
renewed european security dialogue
initiative
we encourage russia to engage in this
format
we also urge russia to respect its
commitments under the vienna document
and contribute to a constructive
dialogue and exchange under chapter 3.
norway upholds a european security order
based on international law and national
serenity and territorial integrity
these principles have repeatedly been
invoked by russia in council discussions
norway calls on russia to respect these
principles when it comes to ukraine
president through threatening posture
and rhetoric and unrealistic demands
russia is challenging european security
every country has the right to freely
choose its security alignment
we cannot allow the established security
architecture to be replaced by spheres
of influence
we're concerned that the ceasefire in
dombust from july 2020 has become
increasingly fragile
we call on the parties to seek a durable
ceasefire and do their utmost to prevent
civilian casualties
the humanitarian situation is severe
after eight years of conflict
civilians are increasingly losing access
to essential life-saving services as
civilian infrastructure is damaged and
destroyed
any escalation of the conflict would
lead to devastating humanitarian
consequences
let me conclude by reiterating norway's
unwavering support for ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
within its international recognized
borders in accordance with the
principles and purposes of the u.n
charter this includes the crimean
peninsula and its territorial waters i
thank you
thank you
mr president
brazil follows with concern the
situation in eastern ukraine
persistent political stalemate and
prolonged crisis have reached a critical
point
in present circumstances
renewed and reinvigorated the political
resolve by all parties is crucial to
address the conflict
achieving and maintaining peace is our
collective responsibility
we appreciate the ongoing political and
diplomatic efforts
aiming to restore peace and instability
in ukraine
and the wider region
we firmly believe a diplomatic solution
must be found to the crisis
and will continue to support credible
initiatives to bring episcopal a
peaceful settlement to it
we reiterate our understanding that
resolution 2202
provides the general guidelines for a
peaceful solution to the situation and
the permanent stability in eastern
ukraine
unfortunately
resolution 2202 has not been fully
implemented
brazil urges all parties to
fulfill the letter and the spirit of the
minsk agreements
we urge
concerned parties to pursue genuine
dialogue on the implementation of
security resolution 22
02 which provides the parameters not
only to address the situation in eastern
ukraine but also to assist diplomatic
efforts to overcome the current security
challenges in the region
brazil also welcomes the resumption of
talks in the normandy format and calls
for renewed commitment to find ways for
a lasting peace in eastern ukraine
a comprehensive ceasefire
which is the first point of the minsk
agreements remains an essential element
in this process
beyond that
we need further disengagement of forces
and military equipment on the ground
this disengagement must allow
unimpeded access of humanitarian
relief to people in most desperate need
furthermore
trust among relevant parties is crucial
to strengthening dialogue
and achieving a sustainable solution
negotiations on the parameters
to grant special status to certain areas
of don donetsk
regions must be conducted with a sense
of urgency
flexibility and spirit of compromise
the implementation of the minsk
agreements must observe full respect for
the sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity of ukraine
all parties must bear in mind the latter
of the agreements
we firmly believe
that the security council has their
utmost responsibility to avoid and
condemn any attempt of a military
solution to these crisis
and negotiation are the only way forward
to a lasting peace
we urge all parties to take the
necessary measures to de-escalate
tensions and play a constructive role in
reaching a political settlement to the
ukrainian crisis in accordance with
international law particularly the u.n
charter
i thank you
thank you very much mr president and i
also want to say a special thank you to
under secretary general de carlo and to
ambassadors kinonan
and javik today for their helpful and
informative briefings and i'd like to
also recognize the presence of
high-level participants at this council
this morning mr president
as i begin my remarks it's important
that i'm clear
ireland is a steadfast and consistent
supporter of ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
ireland believes in
and is fully committed to the core
principles enshrined in the un charter
these include the sovereign equal
equality and territorial integrity of
states
ukraine has the same fundamental right
as every other sovereign and independent
state to choose its own foreign policy
and to ensure the security and defense
of its territory
that is the right we hold to be
self-evident
is the right that ireland struggled to
obtain
as russia's military buildup at
ukraine's border continues to raise
tensions
ireland again calls for calm
de-escalation and the pursuit of
diplomacy
we need to see sustained and credible
moves on the ground toward de-escalation
genuine de-escalation will imply a
significant withdrawal of both troops
and equipment
we commend all who are engaged in
dialogue including through the normandy
format and poland as osce chair and
office for launching a renewed european
security dialogue
we support urgent constructive and
resolute engagement through all
diplomatic channels
president
the full implementation of minsk peace
agreements
and the related conflict resolution
efforts in the normandy format
and trilateral contact group are
important priorities for us
there is no doubt
that we are now at a sensitive moment
today we call on all parties to act
constructively within both formats
in this regard we deeply regret the
decision of the russian state duma to
submit a call to recognize as
independent entities the
non-government-controlled areas in the
donetsk and luhans god bless of ukraine
this would be a clear violation of the
minsk agreements
we are also concerned as reports of
alleged shelling today in eastern
ukraine
as mentioned by special representative
kinnan which would also be a violation
of the minsk agreements
mr president all signatories of the
minsk agreement agreed on the need for
the osce's special monitoring mission
safe and secure access to the entire
territory of ukraine
the mandate of the smm was agreed by all
57 osce participating states
we therefore remained very concerned at
the continuing restrictions imposed on
the smm's freedom of movement
we also regret that smm equipment has
been damaged or interfered with
i want to express our deep regret at the
decision by the russian federation to
refuse to extend the mandate of the
border observer mission to monitor
the border crossings
we commend the tireless efforts of
ambassadors kinanan and chevik in the
trilateral contact group
we see the agreement reached by the
group at the end of last year on
adherence to the july 2020 ceasefire as
an important achievement and a sign that
there can be progress
if there's genuine political will
president
eastern ukraine has already endured
eight years of conflict resulting in
humanitarian disaster
serious human rights violations and
abuses as reported by the ohchr
just as we know that further conflict is
not inevitable
we know too
that wherever conflict occurs it is
civilians who bear the brunt
ireland therefore sincerely calls on all
sides to work peacefully toward an
effective and sustainable political
settlement of the conflict
and to jumpstart that work today
thank you mr president
yep thank you
thank you
for her statement
thank you mr president
let me begin by thanking under secretary
general rosemary dicarlo
special representative mikko kinunen
and chief monitor yesha archevik for
their comprehensive briefings on the
occasion of the seventh anniversary of
the package of measures for the
implementation of the mince agreements
endorsed unanimously by the u.n security
council resolution 2202
i also welcome ms tatyana montyan to our
meeting
we welcome the efforts underway for
implementation of the mints agreements
including through the trilateral contact
group and under the normandy format
we believe that min's agreement provides
a basis for a negotiated and peaceful
settlement of the situation in eastern
ukraine
accordingly we urge all parties to
continue to engage through all possible
diplomatic channels and keep working
towards the full implementation of the
minsk agreements
we also believe that meetings under the
normandy format will further facilitate
the implementation of the provisions of
the mints agreements including its key
security and political aspects
in this context we welcome the recent
meetings of the political advisors of
the normandy format countries in paris
and berlin
we also welcome the unconditional
observance of the july 2020 ceasefire
the
reaffirmation of mints agreements as the
basis of work under the normandy format
and the commitment of all sides to
reduce disagreements on the way forward
any steps that increase tension may best
be avoided by all sides in the larger
interest of securing international peace
and security
quiet and constructive diplomacy is the
need of the r
india has been in touch with all
concerned parties
it is our considered view that the issue
can only be resolved through diplomatic
dialogue
india's interest is in finding a
solution that can provide for immediate
de-escalation of tensions
taking into account the legitimate
security interests of all countries
and aim towards securing long-term peace
and stability in the region and beyond
more than 20 000 indian students and
nationals live and study in different
parts of ukraine including in its border
areas the well-being of indian nationals
is a priority to us
in conclusion we reiterate our call for
the peaceful resolution of the situation
by sincere and sustained diplomatic
efforts to ensure that concerns of all
sides are amicably resolved through
constructive dialogue i thank you
thank you mr president we thank the
undersecretary general
for political peace building affairs
the special representative of the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe
and
the osce special monitoring mission
chief
monitor
for their briefings
kenya cannot contemplate
the continued insecurity in eastern
ukraine
and impact it can have on broader
security in europe
global security is intertwined
instability in europe
beyond threatening lives and economies
also disrupts the ability
of this important region to play a
constructive role
in solving the most pressing challenges
globally
insufficient progress in the
implementation of the minsk agreements
has been realized since 2014 and that
needs to change
kenya wants to offer three brief
recommendations in doing so we hope that
they will contribute to a renewed push
by all relevant stakeholders to
stabilize a situation that left to
escalate threatens the very foundations
of global stability and the security
council's ability to fulfill its mandate
in multiple conflict situations
first
kenya maintains that the respect for the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
all countries by all states is a
cornerstone of global peace
if multilateralism is to be reborn into
a system that delivers sustained peace
to all
the most powerful states
must consistently adhere to
international law and to the respect of
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of all countries in all
regions at all times
we therefore strongly urge all actors to
respect the peace security sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
the people of ukraine deserve inclusive
governance
peace and a vibrant economy which are
all deeply dependent on regional
stability and cooperation
second as we indicated on the 31st of
january in this chamber
we believe that this standoff is
imminently solvable
major military powers particularly those
represented in the security council must
make a specific and sustained effort to
reach arrangements that deliver a
minimum level of the confliction and
mutual respect
otherwise third countries and global
peace and security will suffer greatly
as a result of their confrontations
third
kenya reiterates the obligations of all
the parties to fully implement their
commitments in accordance with the minsk
agreements which provide the most
promising roadmap for the peaceful
settlement of the current hostilities
including in eastern ukraine
all parties must take responsibility and
reflect
that responsibility in a new willingness
to agree to compromise
kenya welcomes the normandy format
advisors meeting held earlier this month
and the follow-up meeting which is
scheduled for next month on implementing
the minsk accords and the consensus
reached at the group leaders summit in
paris in december 2019
we commend
the diplomatic leaders of the russian
federation and the united states and
their partners and allies for showing a
willingness to meet in the coming days
to make further progress
thank you
very much
uh
[Music]
this would
help us to find a peaceful and
sustainable solution that will tackle
all security concerns of all parties
security council resolution 2202.
implementation
agreements more difficult
thank you mr president
thank you very much mr president
i'd like to begin by thanking usg
rosemary dicarlo
for her briefing on the prevailing
situation in eastern ukraine as it
relates to the implementation of the
next agreement
as well as mr miko kuninin
the special representative of the osce
chairperson in the office in ukraine and
the trilateral contact group
and mr yasser halit
shevik
chief monitor of the osce special
monitoring mission ukraine for
highlighting the efforts of the osce
in facilitating the political and
diplomatic
settlements of the ukraine
of of the conflict in eastern ukraine
we have taken note also of the views
expressed by mrs miss tatiana montyan
as a civil society representative from
ukraine
i further welcome the participation of
the representatives of germany and
ukraine
in this meeting
mr president and welcome in today's
discussion
which enabled the council to take stock
of the package of measures for the
implementation of the minsk agreement
adopted on 12 february 2015
my delegation recalls the adoption of
resolution
2202
wherein the security council expresses
firm conviction
that the crisis in the eastern regions
of ukraine could only be settled through
peaceful means
seven years after the adoption of
resolution 2202
the council's obligation for the
maintenance of international peace and
security
requires of it a reiteration of its
conviction
and support for the processes for the
further implementation of the minsk
agreement
unfortunately
the mensk agreements remain largely
unimplemented
and the conflict continues to fester in
parts of the donbass region
with increasing civilian casualties and
deepening vulnerabilities
mostly of elderly persons and women-led
households
more than 14 000 deaths have been
recorded since the conflict in eastern
ukraine began
several thousands of people have been
displaced
and 2.9 million people are presently in
need of humanitarian assistance
the implications of the situation
ukraine on regional
as well as international peace and
security have also been dire
while recognizing the complex fears and
complicated concerns
which have been expressed by the parties
through the minsk agreement
we nonetheless believe that good faith
conformity with charter obligations by
concerned member states
should provide clarity to seize
opportunities
for supporting continuing dialogue
and the engagements required to address
the concerns of all parties
in this respect ghana is concerned by
the increasing tensions along the
borders of ukraine
we recall in this regard the provisions
of the charter which establishes the
fundamental norms of the post-1945
international order and required that
the international relations of member
states should not involve
threats of
all use of force against the territorial
integrity
or political independence of other
states we therefore entreat all parties
to maintain the path of dialogue and
diplomacy
in addressing any differences that exist
between
and among them
towards the further implementation of
peaceful measures for resolving the
crisis in the eastern regions of ukraine
we make the following points
first
gunner reaffirms their support for the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine a bonafide member of the united
nations whose membership
of this organization provides for her
guarantees over her internationally
recognized borders
secondly
we know the security concerns of other
member states in europe especially those
in eastern europe
an edge a restraint by all in
maintaining the pacific order in europe
even as efforts continue
to address any concerns with the
contemporary
european security architecture
third we welcome the high-level
diplomatic engagements to address
existing concerns
over the situation in ukraine
including recent discussions among
leaders of the noman d4
that reaffirmed the ceasefire in the
eastern region of ukraine
as well as the osce facilitated
dialogues at different levels
we continue to age restraint by all
sides
calling the parties to bear in mind the
prospective outcomes from ongoing
escalation
which do not lead to any strategic gain
for any party and i encourage air force
to address both immediate and long-term
interest
through diplomacy and dialogue
fourth we urge renewed dialogue within
the nominee for process
to resolve differences in the
interpretation of the sequencing of the
package of measures
for the implementation of the minsk
agreements
as it has said
how can two go on a journey unless they
be agreed on the path they intend to
take
fifth we urge the parties to guarantee
unimpeded access
for humanitarian assistance in both
government and non-government-controlled
areas
in line with humanitarian principles
and international humanitarian law we
further commend the efforts of
humanitarian agencies in ukraine
and welcome their 2022 humanitarian
response plan
to save lives
ensure access to basic services
and strengthen the protection of those
affected by the conflict and covet 19.
finally mr president let me conclude by
stressing ghana's support
for the renewal of the spirit of the
minsk agreement we urge the parties to
work in good faith and with flexibility
to make necessary concessions when
enduring peace in ukraine
with beneficial outcomes for the rest of
the europe
and indeed globally i thank you very
much mr president
secretariat
you